these questions from Doug in Idaho last
year we cross the 1 million dollar net
worth mile marker way to go dude we did
it all with blood sweat and tears
I credit much of our success to my
frugal wife it's very painful for her to
spend money except when giving to a
charity to the point that she can't
enjoy a vacation or entertain getting a
nicer car for vacation she'd rather go
camping in the National Forest it's 24
degrees here Dave I'd rather spend
$2,000 and go to Caribbean on a nice
warm vacation and eat food I didn't
forage I love my wife more than any
vacation how can I help or not feel
guilty when spending a little money
listen they're people that have a proper
view a proper mental health view of
money are always doing three things
really they're always doing four things
they're always doing something to earn
money even if they don't need to
something and then it'll be a big deal
people who do nothing that's a weird
mental health thing so something to earn
money you need to be giving you need to
be saving and investing and you need to
do wise healthy spending so I strongly
recommend the people do some of all four
all the time with the exception of
something like when you're working the
baby steps but what's happening here is
is that she you know she started her
natural bent is saving and she's never
learned to enjoy money and you're not
doing anything wrong when you enjoy
money as long as you're doing the other
stuff - as long as you're giving and
saving and investing and you're working
then I can promise you David Shannon
Ramsay we enjoy money we work really
hard we give a lot and we enjoy our
money and we save and invest a lot and
so we always are doing all four we've
got this rhythm to our life and so I
think you need to turn it back on and
just say you know
we've worked hard I've worked hard and I
want you to go on this cruise with me
and enjoy it as a favor to me ask her to
do you a favor to do something for you
you love your wife enough to go into the
woods and forage for food but maybe she
loves you enough to go on the cruise
because I got to tell you it doesn't
take many if you're doing nice cruise
and doing nice one dude you're a
millionaire okay don't do one of these
cheap Walmart cruises okay doing nice
one nothing wrong with Walmart but is
that you know what I'm talking about
okay but this is we're going here to
enjoy some luxury and you know make sure
she spends a half day in the spa while
she's there too you know you're a
freakin millionaire and so it doesn't
take much of that to start to figure out
a way to learn to like it
even a tightwad can learn to like it so
I would just I would say listen it's
good mental health it's a good muscle
for us to have a reasonable percentage
of our life a reasonable percentage of
our income that we simply enjoy and I
would push back on that because you
don't you don't want to get to the end
of your life and say I wish I wish I'd
given more I wish I'd traveled I wish I
had done this or should have done that
you don't want to get there you don't
wanna get there and you don't want to
get there and say I wish I'd saved more
because I spent everything because I
thought the whole life is about going on
a cruise it's not or I wish I'd given
more because you never gave anything so
you have to be touching all of these
things you need to be earning and be
spending wisely and enjoying your money
you need to be investing in saving and
you need to be giving outrageously and
you can do all four especially now that
you've hit this millionaire status dude
yes you need to go on a cruise and yes
she needs to agree to go with you and
and if not then I would probably sit
down with a good coach a good life coach
our pastor and just dig into why she is
so freaking tight
was this fear-based is it guilt like
she's done something wrong
I mean what is driving this stuff
you know we address a lot of those
issues in the latest book I did which
was a the legacy journey and you know
the legacy journey is the only book I've
ever done about wealth all the books
have done before been about money and
there's a difference
the legacy journey is the biblical view
of wealth and is it okay to enjoy money
in the does the Bible say it's okay to
enjoy money abso lutely it says it very
clearly repeatedly by the way now this
is that a prosperity gospel why good
gracious no it's just your heavenly
Father saying I'm crazy about you and if
you remember that you're made in your
father's image your heavenly father's
image are made in God's image then some
of the some of the feelings in the
senses the conscience that you have is
his spirit so if you're looking at your
grown children and your grown child was
a millionaire would you be mad at your
grown child if they went on $2,000
cruise wine oh well your heavenly
father's are mad at you either you can
just remember that so if we being evil
know how to give our get kids good gifts
our children good gifts how much more so
our Father in Heaven he wants you to
enjoy your life now if your grown child
was saving no money would you be happy
no well need is your heavenly father in
the house of the wise our stores of
choice food and oil the Bible says if
your if your grown child was deeply in
debt would you be happy no neither is
your heavenly father the borrower's
slave to the lender your grown child was
impulsive and living without a plan
would you be happy no because you know
it's not going to bring them anything
but pain they need to be on the budget
because jesus said don't build a tower
without first counting the cost lest you
get halfway up and you're unable to
finish all who see you begin to mock you
and say this man began to build and was
unable to finish your grown child was
never giving
would you be happy with them no because
you know how giving brings you happiness
God loves a cheerful Giver
or neither would your heavens got to be
happy with you if you never give this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
Oh